foreign
what's up Ashley
hi Dr John thank you how are you
uh other than losing my voice this
morning I'm good excellent well I'm I
sometimes people who are around me wish
I would lose my voice so it's good to
talk to you it's good to talk to you so
what's up
um Okay so
July of 2021 I met a guy
um he was pretty upfront with me in the
beginning
that he was still married
um and that he was going through uh the
divorce process
and that was actually one of the things
that bonded Us in the beginning
um because I had just finalized a
divorce in February earlier that year
um so here's where I have to be really
honest I've never been much of a kid
person
my ex-husband and I we never wanted kids
and it's just never been a plan for my
life
um but here I am really really crazy
about a person that has two kids
um he has an almost 12 year old daughter
and a four and a half year old boy
um unfortunately their mom has made
things really super difficult through
their divorce process
uh maybe because the divorce isn't final
yet
um she's drugged her daughter into
um her mess of emotions they're still
married Ashley oh God okay so she's
oh geez
Okay so
the mom is telling her things you know
Ashley's the reason that your dad left
us
um Ashley stole you from us or Bill your
dad from us
um so as you can imagine the 12 year old
wants nothing to do with me
um they've legally been separated for
two years before I was in the picture
um so I just tried giving the daughter a
ton of grace and patience and not being
too too pushy uh just being present when
when she's around
um and then the four-year-old
he's pretty difficult he's just a
difficult child and in general
um my boyfriend he's a pretty absent dad
due to his job
and he's he's just doesn't really know
how to parent he's absent because he's a
coward
this whole call is about a lack of
respect you don't respect this guy and
you shouldn't
and his ex-wife or his still wife should
not be talking bad about you or him or
any other adults to a 12 year old she's
in the wrong there yes but she shouldn't
just welcome you with open arms because
that's still her husband
right and has been for a couple of years
so you don't respect this guy y'all
bonded over
both being in a mess at the same time
and coming out of a mess he's still
squirrely in it but you were coming out
of a mess and it feels really good when
somebody looks at you and goes yeah me
too
yes and that can have a a
it can feel a lot like love
when you look across a room and your
body recognizes that that guy gets it he
understands
this is how almost every Affair in the
world starts with uh two people who work
together at work and one of them goes
man my husband's really been tough and
he goes
ah man my wife's struggling too and now
we have a shared misery together and it
it's like a pseudo connection it's not
real
right
I don't I mean tell me I I interrupted
what can I do to help I mean this just
sounds like a mess
it is
that's my question is just
how do I go forward being a part of
these kids lives if he and I are gonna
stay together
I mean
you said you don't like them
I can't believe he would be with so I
can't believe a lot of things about this
dude I can't believe he would be with
someone who doesn't like his kids
it's not that I don't like his kids I
never pictured like
be being a stepmom being like in that
in that role I know but yeah you
accepted it
right so either you get real serious
about
um
like if you had no vehicle in the world
to drive none and somebody handed you a
stick shift truck
you know like this is a car it's a truck
it's free for you to use
you would get very serious about
learning how to drive a standard because
you would have to
if you wanted to choose to go to work
and you want to choose to pay rent and
choose to eat right and so similarly
you've are going to go along with this
fantasy for a little while longer and
say that I love this guy I want to be
with him
um
even though he hasn't proven trustworthy
to his ex-wife he's a not a good dad
he's not a person of character integrity
at this moment and but I love him good
good for you
by doing that you have also accepted the
role as I'm inheriting two kids one is
about to be a teenager who's been
through absolute hell
and one is a four-year-old who has never
known stability or peace at home
I'm choosing to enter into that which
means you've got to get Defcon 1 serious
about learning how to parent being in
relationship with taking classes getting
some other women in your life that have
joined Blended families going to
counseling and therapy regularly
that's what you're signing up for by
being with this guy you cannot divorce
him from his kids
okay it's it's evil it's unethical
yeah no that's I would not want to do
that
um and
like can we man can we just be like you
don't respect him do you
I I don't respect how he is as a parent
no
do you respect how he's handled his
marriage
the one he's still in
um that's that's a whole nother story to
get into
um just just yes or no
ultimately no yeah I can hear it on you
why have you trapped yourself in the
it's this guy or bust it's all these
other things that I didn't have
envisioned in my life
but I'm attached to this guy
I was with my ex-husband for 10 years
my entire 20s
I met him when I was 20 we divorced when
I was 30.
why did y'all divorce
um he was an alcoholic and I
banged my head against the wall for lots
of years trying to get him to
stop drinking okay you're heading you're
heading directly into that same storm
with just a different drug
really
yeah I mean
yeah you've gotta you've got a guy who's
not he hasn't decided who or where he
wants to be he hasn't done the hard work
of determining what it's going to take
to get there and he's taken no steps
he's got no disciplines left to go get
there
at any point in the last four years you
accelerate you cash out I'm not gonna
fight for the money anymore I'm gonna
concede a weekend I'm gonna end this
marriage or I'm just gonna keep putting
it along for four years five years six
years and by the way it doesn't even
matter I'm already dating I'm already
seriously dating somebody else
I'm not going to be with my kids I'm not
going to do the things a single dad has
to do
to make sure my kids are stable and okay
I'm just going to my next drug of choice
which is work
and I'll just work and I'll work and
I'll be busy and my kids won't know
their dad but I'll send a check home
that's what he's done
the drug he's an alcoholic he just does
it at work
and in our culture alcoholics
get DWIs and they go to rehab and we
give people addicted to their jobs a
million dollars and say good job
great and they burn everybody in their
world to the ground
because everyone ends up asking from
their spouse to their kids to their
friends huh
what's wrong with what's so bad about me
that I'm not more important than that
email or that meeting
or couldn't you just make that a phone
call why do you gotta go to town for
that
yeah and this is an addict talking to an
addict
I'm a absolute workaholic I have a
problem with it
so much so that my work now when we're
before I take on a big project they ask
my wife
because they want me to be in this long
term and they care about me and my
family
so you're trading you're you are
entering into the same thing again
and I don't want to beat the guy up man
he's clearly got some demons he's
wrestling with I'd love to sit down and
just say bro what are you doing man
because his life is worth more than what
he's cranking out of it too
foreign
here's your path forward
being very very clear about two things
what do you want Ashley you get one shot
man
get one shot what do you want
and then the second thing is what are my
boundaries what am I going to accept
what am I not going to accept
and all the research I've read and
seeing all the people I've met with over
the years
I've never seen a relationship that's
sustained that doesn't have mutual
respect in it
where people wake up and they're like I
don't even like who that guy does but I
respect it gets up and grinds it out
every day I can't stand this guy's boss
I don't like the way her employees treat
her man she gets after it every day
there's just a sense of of respect
right
and ultimately
we talk about pictures you had in your
head you didn't think you were going to
be here at 32 or 33 or 34 did you
no no not at all yeah
so at some point you have to make peace
here's what has happened up until now
and there's a period at the end of those
sentences and right now you're trying to
edit those sentences
in real time and you can't they've
already been written it's over
you got divorced when you were 30. I'm
gonna own that
crap happened between 20 and 30 some of
that was on me some of that was I stuck
around way too long I loved too much
some of that was
the person I was married to was a mess
all it is it happened and the only thing
you can do now is ask yourself that one
terrifying question what am I gonna do
now
am I just gonna cash out and accept what
comes next cool
I for one think your life is worth Matt
actually
and I'm not saying go break up with this
dude maybe it just works out I I
he's still married is all I'm saying he
can tell you any story he wants to
but just out of the gate this thing's
rough I want you to hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of my book own
your past change your future I want you
to read it cover to cover give it to him
as well
and ask yourself the questions at the
end of some of the chapters do the
exercises and I want you to get to the
end and ask yourself okay
what am I going to do now
and if you stay involved with this dude
you better plug directly into those kids
man and you better be real clear with
him about your boundaries and who you're
gonna be in a relationship moving
forward